mm-hmm let's let's look at the average
man's life like I just discussed earlier
how difficult it is how competitive he
has to be and how many problems he has
to fix do you think he wants to handle
any woman okay so dude like the idea of
any degree of problem it's the straw
that breaks the camel's back like the
the point of the point of having a woman
as a man for me at least is for her to
be my peace and quiet I have my life is
stress you see me I'm rolling around
with [ __ ] security teams and I got
problems and they're after me and I I'm
when I come home to my chick the last
thing I want to do is have to handle
anything I want to just sit the [ __ ]
down and her make me happy she used to
be my positive energy she's my sunshine
in the rainstorm okay so you're talking
about him handle you I don't know I
can't answer the question exactly but if
you're sitting there constantly arguing
over small points or correcting him or
that he's probably thinking this is a
battle I don't have the energy to for
another fight